so today I'm going to tell you the best
three stories that I know I think these
stories are absolutely phenomenally
potent and the reason for that is that I
think they illustrate in an
extraordinarily powerful way the nature
of the processes that led to the
establishment of Western democratic
ideals
Mircea Eliade a-- whose work i rely on
substantial substantially to make the
following argument has taken Western
academic culture to task in a manner
that hasn't fully been revealed yet he
said that like all human cultures the
West is parochial and narrow in its
viewpoint and although over the last 300
years there's been a substantial amount
of cross-cultural intermingling and a
potential broadening of philosophical
and religious horizon that broadening
has not been sufficiently complete
if we build on a viewpoint that I've
been developing with you over the last
few courses and make the presupposition
that religious modes of thinking are
more phenomenological than they are
rational which means that they deal more
with what you experience say then with
the objective world if we look at
archaic religious stories through that
lens then they can start to open up and
so given that I want to open up three
religious stories to you today to
in-depth and one only in passing because
we'll return to it later I'll start with
the judeo-christian myth of Genesis when
I say myth I don't mean untruth I mean a
form of knowledge that's narrative in
structure and predicated on presumptions
that aren't empirical a myth describes
processes of transformation a myth
describes the process whereby elements
of experience come into being and
transform the fundamental structural
elements of Genesis are the Word of God
and chaos and the Hebrew words for chaos
and waste our town for chaos and Tohu
for waste and Tom in particular although
Tohu as well are very interesting words
because you can track their derivation
historically and sometimes if you can
track the derivation of words
historically you can get some sense of
the cultural milieu out of which the
word sprang and we know what timeout
means because we have written records of
a story that involves a character named
time out and time out as a dragon who
lives at the bottom of the ocean in the
oldest creation myth we have which is
the enuma elish
the sumerian creation myth samaria
babylon acadia rightly regarded as the
birthplace of modern western
civilization
in Genesis two processes
unite to produce being the first of
those processes or states is chaos
represented by tail or Tohu the second
of those processes is logos and logos is
another word that has an extraordinarily
broad range of meaning it's generally
transcribed in the Christian tradition
as the word and it's identified with
Christ which is a very peculiar
identification because it's the Word of
God that creates order out of chaos and
of course the Word of God in Genesis is
a phenomena that predates the birth of
Christ
infinitely from a classical religious
perspective so the fact that the two
beings are identified is of great
peculiarity and also of great interest
the fundamental story of Genesis is
something like this and it's perhaps the
most brilliant contribution of
judeo-christian thought to world history
it's it's total impact is virtually
incalculable the idea is this that chaos
can be conceptualized as something that
has an essentially feminine aspect as a
matrix and a matrix is a structure from
which other structures emerge and the
story in Genesis makes the hypothesis
that logos which is the Word of God a
phenomena associated with speech and
communication and logic logos logic
rationality courage exploration all
combined into a single entity or trait
logos the combination of logos and chaos
is what brings order into being that's
what the story in Genesis means it's not
an empirical description of the origin
of objects
it's a phenomenological description of
the origin of experience the idea being
that without the piercing glance of
whatever consciousness is whatever the
background of experience is
the matrix chaos cannot be
conceptualized as real it takes the
interplay between the feminine principle
chaos and the masculine principle logos
in order to produce being now lots of
substantial importance when you give
some consideration to the fact that
immediately in Genesis after the
establishment of liveable order the
daddy yahwah identifies as the
individual human being with logos right
made in god's image that's the essential
characteristic of the human being and
what that means is that the logos that
operates in human beings which is this
capacity to make order out of chaos is
identical to the principle that gives
rise to the cosmos from a mythological
perspective so it partakes of the deity
in a very direct sense insofar as being
itself is dependent on its operation now
it's still possible to claim given that
perspective that a story with that sort
of structure is superstitious and it
doesn't bear any relationship to what
actually constitutes reality but you
have to understand that that story old
as it is it's predicated on older
stories and it's on the ground that
those older stories established that our
entire concept of natural rights rests
so if you believe that natural rights
have an existence that's more than
merely arbitrary the reason you believe
that is because they're predicates those
rights are predicated on the ideas that
are expressed in these myths
ok so now we're going to go back in time
to Sumeria I'm going to show you how the
sumerian creation myth lays itself out
and not only that i'm going to describe
to you the direct political implications
of the numinous sumerian creation myth
because the political implications of
that myth are well understood because
the political structure of Sumeria was
directly associated with the structure
of the myth because the Sumerian Emperor
was regarded as the earthly
representative of the highest God in the
Mesopotamian pantheon whose name was
Marduk so insofar as you were Emperor
the reason that you were Emperor and
that this is what gave your sovereignty
legitimacy right because sovereignty has
to have legitimacy otherwise there's
constant revolutions what gave
sovereignty legitimacy in Mesopotamia
was the identification of the emperor
with Marduk and that had certain
implications for the Emperor which we'll
discuss in some detail the story starts
like this you've got this dragon tie
them out and tie them out is a great
primordial beast who lives at the bottom
of the ocean and the ocean is water and
water is associated with the primal
element in archaic thinking and I told
you there's reasons for that already if
you viewed the transformation of deserts
as a consequence of rain can understand
why water would be considered the
element that gives life right that the
element that that brings life forth and
we know from an evolutionary perspective
that that's accurate and we know that
we're 90 percent water and so to
consider water the primal element is no
trivial conclusion no less than
presuming that the Sun is the ultimate
source of life the ultimate god because
the Sun is the ultimate source of life
as far as we're concerned on earth right
because it's the source of all our
energy
these aren't stupid concepts alright so
time out is this horrible creature that
lurks at the bottom of the primal
element all right now she has a husband
AB su now the Mesopotamian creation myth
doesn't say much about Apps ooh we only
know that he's the male consort of the
dragon of chaos
we know from reading other sources of
mythology that the male consort of the
dragon of chaos generally represents
either logos or culture so we're going
to make the presupposition in this
particular case that the husband of
chaos is order or culture okay and then
the Mesopotamians don't say much about
that that that doesn't the development
of the idea of app su or order or
culture doesn't doesn't take new force
until the ancient Egyptians we'll talk
about them today - okay so timeout naps
who are locked into a kind of sexual
embrace according to the Mesopotamian
creation myth and what does that mean it
kind of means two things it means that
they're not really distinguishable
because they're locked into this embrace
and it also means that they're up to
something creative because the act of
sexual congress in mythology is most
usefully is most frequently utilized as
representation of something creative or
as representation of the probability of
some new form coming to be right all
right so Bob sue and timeout are locked
into this embrace in a state that other
creation myths describe as egg like the
pre cosmogonic egg they're intermingling
gives rise to the initial state of being
according to the sumerians and the
initial state of being according to the
sumerians is characterized by the
Dominion of the Elder Gods these gods
being none too bright make a tremendous
amount of racket doing things well what
does that mean exactly well it means
something like this they make a lot of
racket they caused a lot of trouble they
make a lot of wind and all of their
racket and trouble and wind and activity
rouses time at what does that mean well
it means if you do things you get in
trouble it means even if you're trying
to solve problems you get into trouble
because the solution to a problem tends
to generate a whole bunch of new
problems right it's like the Hydra so
what it means is that it's more or less
feted that any form of activity
whatsoever is likely to produce the
threat of catastrophe and of course
we're absolutely keenly aware of that in
the modern world because we're possessed
by this sense that all of our frenetic
activity all of our frenetic motivated
activity is producing alterations in the
world order such that nature itself is
going to be destroyed and eliminate us
and of course we're absolutely keenly
aware of that in the modern world
because we're possessed by this sense
that all of our frenetic activity all of
our frenetic motivated activity is
producing alterations in the world order
such that nature itself is going to be
destroyed and eliminate us right that's
classic sumerian fear nothing's changed
in the last 5,000 years the Sumerians
presume that once the Elder Gods were
constructed and started moving around on
the planet that their activity their
mindless activity because remember these
aren't well integrated motivational
forces they're more like primordial
beasts right they're unintegrated
activity risks plunging everything back
in chaos well tire mats the
representative of chaos this generative
chaos but so what did the Sumerians say
well the Elder Gods cause a lot of
racket they move around the planet and
they upset time at and she decides that
enough is enough and she's going to wipe
them out so she's sitting at the bottom
of the ocean fuming away as the Elder
Gods go about their business and then
they take one step too many and they
kill app suit who's her husband now the
sumerian creation myth doesn't say much
about this but we know that app su is
the male consort of chaos that makes an
order so what happens is the Elder Gods
destroy order itself they destroy
culture itself
and as soon as you destroy culture all
hell breaks loose and that's exactly
what happens in the sumerian creation
myth so time add emerges she's going to
wipe everything out and the world will
revert back to its primordial
non-existent state now the god or gods
get wind of this and of course they're
just terrified because they know that
this thing that gave rise to them
whatever it is the matrix of being can
easily wipe them out at a moment's
notice and so despite the fact that
their transpersonal and immortal and
characterized by a certain amount of
power in the face of absolute chaos
they're insufficient now this occurrence
is extending over a protracted period of
time and as the Elder Gods are
threatened they're also breeding and
mating and producing new forms and they
produce a great great grandson whose
name is Marduk now Marduk has a lot of
very interesting attributes the
attributes are described in the new
militia in the following manner so this
is what marducks father sees when his
wife dam kena gives birth to Marduk so
when he who's Martok's father saw his
son he rejoiced he beamed his heart was
filled with joy he distinguished him and
conferred upon him double equality with
the gods okay so that's the first
indication that whatever mardik
represents is something that's elevated
beyond the normal status of a primordial
deity so that he was highly exalted and
surpassed them in everything artfully
arranged beyond comprehension were his
members not fit for human understanding
hard to look upon for were his eyes for
were his ears when his lips move fire
blazed forth each of his four years grew
large and likewise his eyes to see
everything he was exalted among gods
surpassing was his form his members were
gigantic he was surpassing in height
marry you to marry you to one of his
name's son of the sun-god the son God of
the gods okay complex bit of poetry says
a bunch of things it says well whatever
Marduk is is the offspring of the gods
whatever Marduk is is characterized by
heightened awareness right because he
has four years and four eyes and they're
large whatever Marduk is characterized
by is
status that surpasses that of his
father's whatever he's characterized by
is associated with the power of speech
real power because when he speaks fire
spurts forth Marduk is also huge but
more importantly he's associated in this
particular poem with the Sun why is that
well the Sun dominates consciousness
right because we're conscious during the
day most of our brain is visual cortex
so are visual creatures so when the Sun
rises is when the day begins
so Marduk is also associated with
whatever Danny dominates the day and
that's the deity of consciousness and
there's more to the story of the Sun
right because the Sun is also something
that rises and sets repeatedly and that
means that the deity that dominates
consciousness is characterized by a
cyclical nature that's a Sun myth Sun
rises in the morning renewed as a
consequence of fighting a terrible
battle in the night with the enemies of
everything that's associated with
consciousness a classic solar myth so
absolute time at give rise to the world
of the Gods the activity of the world of
gods reawakens time out she decides to
destroy everything but at that moment
the gods give birth to Marduk now that's
a typical motif which is that the hero's
always born at the time of maximal
crisis and the reason for that is in
part it's simple look if your culture is
dealing well with the forces of the
unknown so that everything is static
static but productive so that problems
themselves don't arise there's no reason
for the hero right there's no reason to
confront the unknown it's only when
crisis beckons that the birth of the
hero is necessary
Marduk constitutes the birth of the hero
and they say look you know we're in real
trouble unless someone goes out there
and confronts time at straight-on she's
going to wipe everything out it's a
dangerous and terrifying job but
somebody has to do it and marek says
well that's no problem but I got a few
rules here and this is the first rule
I'm in charge from here on for
word what does that mean exactly well
these archaic stories are Paula CMAs in
our policy m'q in Northrup fries
terminology what that means is that they
can be met read validly at multiple
levels of analysis simultaneously and so
one thing it means is that if you take
the two-year-old child who's essentially
under the Dominion of assorted
primordial gods and goddesses right
aggression fear panic and according to
Freud a certain degree of sexual
aggression the child moves from
domination from motivated state to
domination from motivated state and it
isn't until the age of three and four
when under the pressure applied by the
social world and as a consequence of the
maturation of the prefrontal cortex
which matures throughout childhood and
adolescence and doesn't reach its final
form until perhaps into the early 20s
all of those fundamental motivational
forces start taking on a structured
relationship to one another which is to
say that once you're as your personality
becomes integrated a single motive force
forward has to bring all of these
underlying motivational systems into
some sort of harmonious arrangement okay
so let's let's see what the Sumerians
are doing here okay first of all they're
they're doing psychology they're trying
to figure out given the Dominion of the
Elder Gods the indisputable Dominion of
the Elder Gods instincts who should rule
right what should be in charge how do
you construct a hierarchy of values and
then more complexly when you integrate a
state which is what the Mesopotamians
did right the first great civilization
what does that mean the first time
hundreds of tribes were hammered into
some sort of stable hierarchical order
how do you represent that order
so Margot gets his act together the gods
all meet in a huge chamber they elect
him King and then they prepare him for
battle when the gods the fathers beheld
the power of his word they were glad and
in homage saying Marduk is king they
bestowed upon him a scepter a throne in
a royal robe
they gave him an irresistible weapon
smiting the enemy saying go and cut off
the life of time at may the winds carry
her blood to out-of-the-way places after
the gods his fathers had determined the
destiny of Marduk they set him on the
road the way to success Entertainment so
then he goes to the heart of darkness so
to speak and confronts timeout accuses
her of treachery and challenges her to
battle when taya mad heard this she
became like one in a frenzy and lost her
reason she cried out loud and furiously
to the very roots her two legs shook
back and forth she recited an
incantation repeatedly casting her spell
as for the gods of battle they sharpened
their weapons time out and Marduk the
wisest of the gods advanced against one
another they pressed on the single
combat and approached for battle okay
well things don't go out so well with
time out from this point forward the
first thing that Marduk does is
encapsulate her in a net and I think
that's a really interesting metaphor
because that's essentially what human
beings do when they encounter the
unknown right they encapsulated in an
explanatory network so it's a way of
binding up the the anomaly or the
unknown and giving it a substantive form
then he cuts her into pieces and then he
makes the world out of her pieces in
fact one of Martok's names is he who
makes ingenious things as a consequence
of the combat with taya meant
oh that's very very interesting because
what it means is that the Sumerians are
presenting in metaphorical form the
notion that when the chips are down the
survival of being depends on the
capacity of whatever mardik represents
the solar God to encounter the
matrix of being to cut it into pieces
and to make the world if you think about
it in those terms it's a very very
straightforward story right it's
basically the story of human beings
fundamentally the story of human beings
because we in the words of a famous
evolutionary psychologist whose name
completely escapes me we occupy the
cognitive niche right our mode of being
is creativity in the foot in the face of
the unknown and when chaos threatens the
established mode of being it's necessary
for us to put our creativity into action
and to carve out new territory or
territory as a consequence of encounter
with the unknown why well because we can
take the world apart with our hands and
put it together in new ways and then we
can scold what we've done verbally and
we can transmit it to another person and
then they can do the same thing and
we're all doing this all the time and
we're all telling each other how we're
doing it and that's how the embodiment
of logos in the human being which is
precisely equivalent to the Sumerian
notion of Marduk that's precisely how it
is that we're constantly capable of
redeeming the world and that's why you
make resolutions at new years because
the new you is supposed to be born at
the new year okay so what are the
Mesopotamians do with the new year they
take their king and they bring them
outside the city now you have to
understand that outside the city is
chaos right because these are
city-states when you go outside the
Dominion of the human you're in chaos
and then the priest makes the Emperor
kneel and takes all his marks of status
off him so he's reduced to his essence
fundamentally the reft of his social
persona and then he slaps him with a
glove and humiliates him and the king is
refor stew recount his sins right
everything he did in the last year that
wasn't up to Marduk standards so to
speak and you can see I'd be a pretty
useful thing to have somebody who's in
power do on a regular basis right
because it reminds them that they're in
fact subject to a transpersonal
structure whose nature isn't precisely
evident but is nonetheless there
which is the case act like Marduk or all
hell will break loose and demolish your
kingdom which is of course is true now
as it was then so the Emperor gets
humiliated he has to recount his sins
then he's locked up then he re-enacts
the battle with Tiamat and when he
emerges victorious he's locked up with a
ritual prostitute a higher duel and they
mate why well the Huayra do love the
ritual prostitute represents tire mat
now why the hell would that be because
time outs a dragon right a horrible
man-eating dragon that lives at the
bottom of the ocean which is to say that
in any encounter with the unknown as
difficult traumatic and violent as that
might be there's also the possibility
for something creative to emerge as a
consequence right because it's out of
the unknown that we mind new information
so insofar as the Mesopotamian Emperor
acted out the role of Marduk then he was
a good Emperor than he deserved his
sovereignty and literally as well as
figuratively insofar as he didn't play
that role then the society was going to
remain not only stable but constantly
updated because he's engaged in this
constant creative contact with the
unknown
aided and abetted by his attempts to
remember his own inadequacies and
weaknesses and to do something about
them okay so that's a pretty interesting
story and it gets even more interesting
when you start to understand that the
judeo-christian creation myth is
assimilated to the sumerian creation
myth by the union of the notions of
chaos and Tiamat so the logos in
judeo-christian thinking the Word of God
that produces order out of chaos is also
essentially equivalent at least
metaphorically speaking to whatever
marduk represents in the sumerian
creation myth and we know that our
relationship with the anu may allah is
obscured by time but our relationship
with the stories that lay out the
fundamental substructure of western
culture is not so ameliorated even
though we may not believe them
explicitly anymore they still sit at the
basis of our society
you